[Music]
in trolls being trollsnews submitted by
big juicy dumplings the way you say it
the way where that said it like inspired
all your the same time to make the same
noise well when you said I had like
drool in my mouth others police issue a
warning to people who mocked a wanted
criminals receding hairline may issue a
warning you know do that anymore
stop making fun of our image pretty much
so uh all right so this criminal they
were searching for him and people just
could have stopped making fun of I can't
wait to get posted like on the
department's Facebook or something okay
yeah I live for this [ __ ]
so should I show you the photos first or
give you the jokes first we need the cuz
then you guys are gonna read your home
it was like a Simpsons character that
guy looks like Mugatu yeah that smells
like I've seen his hair before
that's his inspiration that's Will
Ferrell's character like it's very like
flames it looks like a dancing in
Medellin he's like a real-life clown he
had no other option than to go into
crime yeah it could have shaved the back
part then looked fine the thing is like
if you look at him if he would just
shave it off you look alright yeah
exactly like why just not shaven I guess
maybe he doesn't have access to a razor
no when he's on death row game looks
like if he was upside down he would have
the same face oh my god what if he was
in the middle of getting implants or
something oh so little jokes they were
saying one commented he walked out of
the complex at precisely 7:30 p.m. in
his hairline at 7:45 p.m.
the one he was last seen in town police
are combing the area another one pushed
his release date back further than his
hairline that should teach him
no one's commenting on the [ __ ] two
little antennae that he has like they're
talking [ __ ] about his hairline I come
up with one line or even a line it's
just yeah it's more like this is our pun
they're like one Leonard popsicle stick
job yeah so they're saying that there
were more than 84 thousand comments and
14 thousand shares on the post before
the poiice department deleted it but
before they good interaction for the
police department
because they're just roasting him so
this is what they commented before they
deleted the post [ __ ] is the Quint
coincidence in a UK oh it says please
remember that harassing threatening and
abusing people on social media can't be
against the law art it's in the UK
different there yeah to be as careful on
social media as you would in any other
if you talk [ __ ] online you could get in
trouble by the law that's what they're
saying that's [ __ ] crazy dress of it
so they're saying if you say something
about someone which is grossly offensive
or is of an indecent obscene or menacing
character then you could be investigated
by the police so they're like we're
really grateful to everyone who is
assisting us in locating Jermaine Taylor
and we must admit we must admit a few of
these comments have made us laugh
however when the line is crossed from
being funny to abusive we do have to
make sure we are responsible and remind
people to be careful Oh [ __ ] oh man
remember that harassing threatening and
abusing people a social media can be a
pear a Singh okay was Jermaine Taylor
what I'm getting from this is roasting
people is considered abusive in the UK
yeah that's [ __ ] insane dude so so
technically that's why I don't have any
[ __ ] mass shootings maybe that's it
maybe we should just block everyone's
speech and you eat it
we wanna know they also don't have guns
though they really don't have mass
diving's mass stabbing yeah they have
mass cabbie
they have badly have people driving into
people with cars and [ __ ] yeah mass
drive
you know date they had am a stabber in
Japan and we were there or like right
when we left am a stabber
it smells like masturbating and I can't
stop being yes
that boy like to soar and you know Park
and he [ __ ] started mass stabbings
he's is there enough yeah
aiding mass masturbator I'm just
mind-blowing that like all these people
are having fun and they're roasting this
dude and they could go they could go to
jail [ __ ]
yeah that's that's it's death that's
crazy gymnast did not have access to
social media in jail yeah well they're
what they're worried about him being
made fun of right online I think I guess
I mean they just don't want to promote
this culture of being able to roast
people and make low popsicle jokes at
them because if that's considered abuse
and what is it harassment her rat like
what the [ __ ] I think we need to know
what he went to jail for to even know if
he deserves being made time I think he
should be made fun of by the way he
looks I think that's okay dude in the UK
do they just arrest all YouTube
commenters cuz goddamn that's true
can you subpoena who the [ __ ] be writing
nasty [ __ ] I would like to know wait
like which comment prompted them to to
have this warning and then for them to
delete this post because they don't
really go into details from from them
reporting it like the media maybe
they're just like alright that's enough
everybody like that's their way of being
like calm down because if they delete
the post then that means I mean 84,000
people saw this and commented or maybe
more people saw it right so that's
actually good work on the police's part
cuz now it's gonna help them find behind
the trash get in the middle hairs pop
out I mean once he shaved his head
everybody's like just he's just some
ball guys not together dude that guy is
not hard yeah that's true but if you
kept his hair that way he's not hard to
miss man if you shaved your
head and they grew your beard more you
just look like any dude who had a shaved
head and that's true man it's easy to
describe crazier he looks like Jesse
smaller he looks kind of like a Donald
donkey yeah he looks like Jesse small it
doesn't a little bit but give him if he
had long hair right no longer here I
just want to understand how that hair
came to life what was his inspiration
you know maybe he's a comedian as part
of his bit and he's holding on to the
hair that he has left and he won't let
it go like you know how some people
dysmorphia this who has hair dysmorphia
he thinks he's rocking a flattop right
now yeah yeah you know no one no there
he looks like the different kid in play
yeah he's got a smooth like flattop when
he got it and when he lifted his hat it
oh man oh yeah it definitely looks like
if he put the one side of velcro that
sticks to the other thing hard [ __ ] to
get out
maybe our UK fans can explain to us like
their laws because I guess just being
here it kind of blows my mind how people
can get in trouble for making jokes yeah
because it's kind of subjective if it's
a joke if that is harassment or not well
I mean the way society like the entire
world is just heading towards a way more
PC we're like conforming it's like the
black mirror episode which one which one
where she goes she like sets [ __ ]
finally and like she goes gets put in
jail or Ron Howard's daughter we're like
you have to get points for Instagram
yeah or she wants to up her social yeah
yeah and then like she says [ __ ] a
couple times and people like downgrade
her and then she ends up in jail for
saying like I know like I don't know cuz
it makes me think a lot about like the
freedom of speech laws here and how
they're changing cuz even on social
media everyone has to be so careful and
so PC and we have to be careful now too
because everyone is just like really
like they're taking them know about
that's scary to me though is so we have
freedom of speech that's a government
thing that's a law thing but then on
social media these are private
companies but they're bending towards
yeah they're bending it in their own way
but it's also where it's almost as if
these there is no other choice even
though they're private companies and
yeah they can do whatever they want but
there is no government Instagram or a
government YouTube or whatever so to be
and so it makes it like Instagram and
YouTube are a necessity of regular day
life and you have to abide by these new
rules which are kind of going against
the Constitution well kind of but I
think what from what TIFF was reading
about what UK is trying to do and
something that I kind of like would side
with that I hope would never Trump on
freedom of speech is the fact that
they're trying to take away violent like
like oh kill this guy or make sure like
that type of hate speech no no but that
for you yeah those are threats yeah
that's a threat and that's already
illegal here you're like where do you
draw the line cuz now it's getting
blurry er yeah want me to you but it is
it isn't here but we're getting that
like we're on logical medium we get that
yeah and that's illegal right yeah and
then it's punishable by law which is
cool but then they're taking the actual
effort of moving in that direction
saying hey if we catch you whereas
everybody has to effort though they're
not because they're saying if you're
saying that [ __ ] we're gonna arrest you
or if you make fun of his hair lamb or
arresting you guys yeah I think the
learner or not yeah if you make a pun in
your roast then it's not it's not a
threat if you make a pun it's clearly a
joke that's why I brought up that I wish
I would have known what prompted them to
say this because we don't know that what
no yeah yeah so we don't know what else
was written but you look at the article
ones one off the article right so the
three examples that the articles gave
that prompted the police to shut it down
I'm like what the [ __ ] that's just like
I get both of you like so we were going
off the article and you guys are like
well maybe there's things not in the
article that we're actually more
threatening and but based off of the
police's response they're not talking
about threats they're talking about the
subjective interpretation of harass
offensiveness harassment gonna be
the exact quotas if you say something
about someone which is grossly offensive
or is of an indecent obscene or menacing
character they you could be
investigating the subjective so so
here's the difference right there's
morally wrong or what is ethically wrong
in society versus law so that is very
subjective and it makes it very
difficult when it comes to law how do
you how do your holidays that's
something that that yeah and it might be
socially and morally may be wrong to be
offensive and maybe roast someone and be
be a bully but then does that make it
illegal that is the question
so then the police enforcing something
that is so subjective and you don't know
one thing that could be offensive to to
this group can be totally not offensive
to this group and we just don't know is
showing your shoulders is offensive
cultures but is it against a lot No
yeah so and and so I think we're having
two different conversation here right so
like is it is it Polly scible is it
punishable is it illegal to do something
that might hurt someone's feelings are
illegal yeah is it illegal shoulders
offensive maybe but but but yeah and and
and and I think a group of people who
feels that something is ethically wrong
in society should be illegal and I think
that's what's blowing my mind because in
the UK here it seems like that's illegal
but who is the gatekeeper to say what is
offensive
yeah because even understatement they
wrote like there's some things in there
that even made us laugh so yeah we don't
know yeah so then if it's funny to us no
but it hurts someone's feelings
should we go to jail or should we get
ticketed or should we get in trouble
nice see that's what's blowing my like
what though that's what happened with
your and with the swastika puppy
comedian dude yeah it's offensive but is
it illegal right yes yeah yeah what's
changed and this is part of the reason
why shits gone so craze in our country
what's changed is before we could all
roast this guy but now if I roast this
guy everybody in the world can see
you're shaming there's already there's
always been people that are racist and
[ __ ] like that but now they can and not
like we don't deal with the consequences
of free speech anymore you know I'm
saying if you used to got in a street
corner and say you know blah blah blah
racist races races whatever you say
people might [ __ ] you up people are
gonna [ __ ] you know that now you can
say behind the anonymity of a keyboard I
mean I'm kind of veering from this guy
with the weird haircut but I'm saying
like we don't have to deal with the
consequences of our friends speech
anymore we have a bullhorn that
everybody can hear like when they wrote
freedom the freedom of speech laws
that's us talking in this room yeah they
thought that humans would be decent
enough to control themselves because
there's like consequences physical
punishment other people might [ __ ] you
up if you say something mean or whatever
right yeah and so this might be a
reaction to people having that Anonymous
like status online and being able to say
the most racist craziest things and then
people are like we got to do we got to
get the police to do something here this
is why our president is a white
supremacist because this white
supremacist [ __ ] you know I know because
I used to [ __ ] go into a gas station
and if they look outside and they look
around and there's no black people there
they'll start talking [ __ ] about black
people you bet I've been I was in a bar
when Obama got elected and her people
call him man word and [ __ ] like that
video but every race oh it's always been
here but now you know in the 80s and 90s
they couldn't you you had to keep that
[ __ ] under wraps
now people [ __ ] put it out and
project it and now all those people are
getting much more like yeah [ __ ] y'all
I'm standing up like yeah white
supremacist whatever like there it's
embolden enabled to put it out without
dealing with the direct consequences of
their free speech and that's why we have
a white supremacist president I guess
okay it's offensive right and I don't
like white supremacy and I don't like
racism but I also believe in freedom of
speech and if that's their opinion I
think they have every right to say it
and I [ __ ] hate them for saying it
but that's the country that we live in
we get to be like that guy's an [ __ ]
their freedom to be able to say that is
the same freedom that I have to say [ __ ]
you I don't believe in what you believe
in I agree I think you should be able to
be racist if you want to be racist but
I'm saying like you it used to be that
you want to go be in the KKK you might
be walking on Street and somebody [ __ ]
you up for it or at least you have to
deal with the direct consequences of
being in it yeah now you can just be in
your basement like yeah you're right
yeah there's no confidence yeah
I still am on your side I don't think it
should be I still think free speech is
more as important but it is true that it
emboldened people because they don't
have to get down to deal keyboard
warriors [ __ ] them
[Music]